it's amazing to meet you it is simply
extraordinary
maybe this will all make sense if I
explain Who I am my name is dr. Ellie
staple and I'm a psychiatrist my work
concerns in a particular type of
delusion of grandeur it's a growing
field I specialize in those individuals
who believe they are superheroes good
for you
the three of you have convinced
yourselves you have extraordinary gifts
like something out of a comic book David
Dunn the only person to survive that
trainwreck all those years ago what do
you do I'm in security you think you
have superpowers
it's a feeling vision I have to touch
them you believe you are a protector
my name is Patricia I have no question
there are two dozen identities I'm Mary
Reynolds senior we almost got to that
live in that body with you the Beast is
coming any minute now for you guys but
what I am questioning is your belief
that you are something more than human
and yet it is true my bones break easily
and I've had 94 breaks in my life but
you have an extraordinary thank you this
is not a cartoon
this is the real world no way
and yet some of us still don't die with
bullets
some of us can still bend steel I've
been waiting for world to see that we
exist may I'll meet the Beast I hope for
your sake that he likes here that sounds
like the bad guys teaming up a lot of
people are going to die
don't do this are you ready
what do we call you sir first name mr.
last name I'm scared professor
dumbledore everyone you're scared of
something
what is this yes you're next
that's an unusual one what mr. Scamander
fears above everything else is having to
work in an office sir go ahead and use
ridiculous
[Music]
magic rooms only in rare Souls still win
stealth in shadows of the old ways serve
us no longer take it we've heard the
rumors of all television but he will
rise to dominance over the Wizarding
World
so you're asking me to help hunt him
down
I can't move against Grindelwald it has
to be you in your shoes I'd probably
refused to there's light that he leaned
it oh come on
[Music]
you underestimate your talents missus
come on
their arrogance is a key to our victory
muggles are not lesser
not disposable
but you could meet you never met a
monster you couldn't love freeze
mr. Scamander do you think tumble to
will known for her
[Music]
are you ghost
no I'm alive but I'm an alchemist and
therefore immortal oh you got a funny
Jake across oh oh you don't look a day
over 375 our world is changing
the mass extinction we feared has
already begun and we are the cause we
are the infection
[Music]
but like all living organisms the earth
unleashed a fever to fight this
infection its original and rightful
rulers the Titans for thousands of years
these creatures have remained in hiding
around the world and unless all the
Titans are found our planet will perish
and so will we
they are the only guarantee that life
will carry on
[Music]
you are out of your goddamn minds I am
sorry but this is the only way
[Applause]
[Music]
long live the king
[Music]
you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can take care of myself when
you're 18 give these people a chance
because that's what they're giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson makes vitae make
him feel at home
they seem nice but don't buy it
it gets real Game of Thrones around here
dude just mess around you look at me and
you're like why so dark you're just able
to foster kid you've got it all if you
could have one superpower what would you
think everybody chooses flight you know
why so they can fly away from this
conversation no cuz heroes fly well you
need a fake family to stand up for you
hey man sorry about that
Billy Batson
I choose you
as champion
hello
say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir
wait for you okay
Shazam Billy you're the only person I
know that knows anything about this Cape
Crusader stuff tonight yeah that's crazy
right what are your superpowers super
powers dude I don't even know how to pee
in this thing fly okay why are you
talking
oh no I don't think that's gonna bus out
your phone charge your phone charge
he'll take you like a bad guy right
you have full immunity I will prove
you're dead sorry about your window
you're welcome for not getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero
[Music]
my father was a lighthouse keeper my
mother was a queen but life has a way of
bringing people together could unite our
worlds one day
check it out author it's talking to the
fish
they made me what I am
permission to come aboard
[Music]
I've been looking for you your half
brother King arm is about to declare war
upon the surface world
the only way to stop this war is for you
to take your rightful place as king
trust me I know you do your best
thinking when you're not thinking at all
that was the worst pep talk ever
I want to strap in
my brother has come from the service
challenge me for the throne I got an
ass-whooping
[Music]
no leader
okay because I have no choice
you can't save my home and the people
that I love you think you're unreachable
lead because you have two different
worlds
that is exactly why you are worthy
was awesome
a war is coming to the surface
and I'm bringing the wrath of the seven
seas with me
[Music]
what are you doing a parachute right
hoods
[Music]
[Music]
everything led me here to you you're the
boy from the circus please can you help
me
[Music]
we're back
there is something people inside of me
they're scared again but you can control
them
don't know what at the cop
[Music]
sometimes when I feel the darkness you
feel
[Music]
my mom says there's no such thing as
monsters I used to think that I was
wrong says here you were a lawyer until
not that long ago what changed
I'm sorry about your brother Jimmy you
know you can take some time off
nobody's gonna ding you for not having a
steady job right this minute let's get
it over with
you know rip the band-aid off right
that's your new job I made my own house
at the moment
you have guts France respect I don't to
keep that if I were you
think you're really gonna like this just
not for me and I don't think it should
be for you either
do you have something to tell me if you
do you would be well-advised to do so
let's do something beautiful here we
make a bundle it's free money every hour
every day yeah good chunka chunka
good jump we're gonna had some rough
road
you know why God made snakes before he
made lawyers he needed the practice
that's pretty much the only lawyer joke
I know because all the others are true
stories we have always looked to the
stars to discover when we are
and hidden there was a message the
secret made of space in time visible
only to those open enough to receive it
Captain Christopher Pike request
permission to come aboard
what commander this is awkward but the
best way to give into a cold stream to
jump right in
I'm here to stay commander the discovery
under regulation 19 Section C your
directive is only institution with an
eminent threat is detected the
Federation sensors picked up seven red
verse spread out across more than 30,000
light-years these mysterious signals are
beyond anything we understand is it a
greeting a declaration of malice let's
find out
aye sir
[Music]
six seconds to impact I am in total free
fall trust us
go Barry has you right ladies absolutely
we have someone in common my foster
brother mr. Spock
he took leave it says that feed run into
a question he couldn't answer
Spock is linked to these signals and he
needs help
we're on a collision course with a
pulsar what a relief
thought we were all gonna die
wherever our mission takes us
trying to have a little fun along the
way
[Music]
ruffle a few feathers I look forward to
it
hidden
[Music]
excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me
- you're okay you look a little yes I
hear it's going around bless you
[Music]
the names Rex but you'll call me captain
or sir war does not come with a
guarantee no soldier gets the promise of
safety why does the kitchen is trooper -
seven - five five five five sir
we call him fives I'm heavy this is echo
I'm Commander Cody your new boss so yes
looks like we got ourselves a batch of
shinies commander look around well one
of the same same heart same blood your
training is in your blood my Bloods
boiling for a fight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right Rex what's so important that
you brought us all the way back here
hello master it's been a while
[Music]
you
you
[Music]